you
team black the magic number was 16 can I
go for H 2 even in haha the Alpen there
goes my thoughts of H 2
White's looking to build a center I was
gonna say can I still go for H 2 even in
a blitz game ok it's likely no I was
just gonna say it's likely the case that
I end up with an isolated Queen pond
if white had captured on this square I
was gonna capture with my pawn go with
the pawn or the Queen I think so let's
do this um do you know why I'm playing
without knight c6 can you see it can you
see why it's because of this he was a
bad man these guys these fixed pawns in
the center tell us which bishops are
good and which bishops are bad
and he's a bad man right here because he
gets obstructed by these ok do I take or
just develop um with this pawn on e5
it's of course a little bit awkward to
complete King side development so maybe
I don't bring my Queen night here and I
play something like this and bring him
here or do I capture here for it I think
I want to I I do have some fear and that
fear is this c4 move
that's a double if I play this maybe
pawn takes is annoying let's just take
here quit you're talking I take here
again let's do that clarify that pawn
structure I don't want to deal with
takes I recapture with my bishop for my
queen and then this Queen side expansion
with B for a4 a5 I've seen that before I
don't like getting kicked around
who does really right raise your hand
okay I thought that that was the correct
way to recapture I guess while I was
considering with the night I could see
that with the night taking this F pond
starts - well it's he's freed up but so
night my Queen night here although this
is a good outpost as well I'm gonna go
with this this is this is way too
natural square not to go there right
away and I wonder if I should be
preventing this advance I weaken this
square but um I think it's I think it's
important then maybe one day I could
play here and that would involve
clamping down on b3 and then a night
here - here move okay so the queen is
tethered to the defense of this pond do
I still play this move maybe I do
mm-hmm oh let me get some more
development in here my opponent has has
been flying with the moves so far and
Knight here would come with an attack on
this pond I want to play here and then
secure my Knights position if I play
here in g4s plate I could take you'll
notice any pin that white tries to get
me and I could get out of it with the
capture so I could play here I was more
concerned about the night playing to
this square so now that it's defended
let me make sure I have my Knights
position secured it's usually the case
that trading Queens in the Cairo con
which is what this is reminding me of
right now since I have the light-square
bishop Soph the board it's usually good
idea let's let's trade Queens who can it
be avoided another Queen would have to
play here which is a little bit awkward
I'm playing what I'm playing for right
now is a good night versus a bad Bishop
ending or a good Bishop versus a bad
Bishop ending or maybe better summarized
I want to make sure that this Bishop
does not exchange its
alfe for anything I want him to stay
around I want him to stick around for
forever there's a better way to say that
but I'm yeah I don't I don't want what
don't I want I don't want losing my
train of thought here I don't want him
to exchange himself off for anything and
I like my Knights position I don't want
to deal with G for it granted he is on a
dark square now let's back up
yeah let's back up maybe this oh you
hear that siren in the back there is a
little siren in the back okay and
there's food for that right there
fun little fact I should say all right
can i weasel my knight around or
something all right let's try and fix
another pond on a dark square this one
I'm gonna meet with this probably gonna
have both Brooks off the board and I'm
gonna keep my knight here I want to make
sure I recatch with my king because I
want to be able to meet Knight here with
this move okay and now I think I start
to be a lot better in this position
let's see how true that is
let's clog things up I'm not sure how I
would read this is mines instinct to
capture like that I like my Rick
position okay let's let's let's do this
I'm not gonna take with my rook I want
to be able to play I want to get my
knight here that's the main reason I
want to no post for my knight I've
actually caught up these last handful of
moves on the clock is the King running
over here to grab this pawn that's my
only weak link and again everything is
directed my play has been ever since
getting rid of my LightSquared bishop it
has been to give this check you know
what I'm not gonna go here right away
let me let me make these pawns flinch a
little bit are they gonna flinch Oh
all right we're gonna have we're gonna
have this aren't we yes we are
all right let's let's take here they
were gonna take I think I need to play
my rook to Fe maybe my king he jump over
to b5 get my king up here I'm looking to
take and then play bishop here let's
take oh that's you had to take like that
that's what I was setting up that's why
I played my rook here so I could capture
and then I knew that there would always
be if I did that one move earlier I knew
that there would be a bishop blot are a
pond block so that's why I did this okay
f8 moved before I had captured so that
actually a sudden end all of a sudden
that rook on c1 becomes he's toast right
let's back up that was a let's see it
turned out Sicilian out or excuse me it
started out as if it would be a Sicilian
Alpen but we quickly transposed into a
French where I'm simply looking to
exchange off my bad Bishop that's what
this Queen b6 line does I think there
are opportunities for you to try for
this c4 move when you see me play Queen
b6 it's it's it's pretty much a tell
that I am trying for this maneuver when
you see a delay with the Queen Knights
movement to c6 since that that would
interfere with the Bishop b5 stuff maybe
maybe there's a better move than Bishop
here I think I think there is a
difference between e 2 and D 3 I can't
go into analysis mode so you just have
to picture this if Bishop e2 and then I
follow up with b5 notice how it's
different I think there is this the c-4
move
and if I take with the pond then you
advance d5 it's a structural change to
be aware of on the white side or after
Bishop e2 again after Bishop e2 Bishop
b5 c4 if I take with the bishop you take
with my bishop from e2 i recapture and
yet again there's this d5 move that
changes the structure so that's
something to look into that is a
difference between e 2 and D 3 just
right out of the gates right out of the
opening because since it's on d3 after I
play to this square if you're playing c4
I could take with the pawn and it comes
with tempo I'm on your Bishop and so
there's no time for this d5 advance
we're not in that situation but it's
something to look into a way to reply to
this idea of getting rid of the bad
bishop I think it was important for me
to stop b4 if b4 is loud then my knight
has to wonder you know is he gonna be
kicked around with b5 or maybe maybe not
I don't know maybe a6 was okay if b4 is
played maybe I could just be going a
single step but I do have to be a bit
cautious about the c5 square b4 is
played this idea of Knight c3
a for c5 can be quite annoying this is
this turns out to be a bit of a
sensitive square c5 it didn't didn't
turn out like that in this game but you
know and maybe a slight improvement I
wonder is if it's instead of knight here
which seems very natural what about
bishop here bishop here if i play my
knight to this square you have g4
because you're defending d4 enough I'd
have to come back or maybe you know what
I would do
yeah if Bishop b2 all I would do is h5
and you're probably just transposed so
that's not really a big deal so we get
into this where the Queen's are off
and it seems pretty even you're just
trying to find a new home for the night
you'd really like to be here or here and
so that's what white is trying to do
with that move and you know what I think
what's best is to just make sure you get
all the rooks off the board I think if
I'm able to play this b5 and cement a
rook here and if it's ever captured I'm
recapturing it and having a connected
passed pawn in a nice home for my knight
on b5 I think that should not be allowed
excuse me so instead I think it may be
your best chance for success your your
best objective move would be to get both
rooks off the board that's just my quick
thoughts on that because it again I'm
able to plant up on c4 eventually well
we still have a pair of books on the
board and my opponents doing doing well
to recognize the strong placement of my
eventual knight on b5 so with the center
blocked and everything it's you you do
have times for time for these retreating
type of moves I'd like to not have I'd
like to still have my knight having
pressure on that pun but my opponent
negated that and in this final position
you're just needing to capture like this
and what I was going to be doing after
pawn takes I was going to be playing b5
and then you still can't take and then
rook here would be needed and I think
well I don't know well you know what my
rook is gonna get very active even even
in you know this did end right away with
Bishop here I think it's maybe close to
still lost with after this capture g5
rook f1 seems forced pawn takes pawn
rook takes pawn
no it's still it's not working yeah cuz
I haven't eventually still end up with a
pin pon takes g5 I'm threatening this if
ruk f1 pawn takes rook takes I have yet
again this Bishop g5 move so it becomes
very awkward for you to defend f4 if
you're not capturing with f4 and if you
do then you have of course that skewer I
was again this I guess the big summary
with this game was trying to make sure
this guy remained bad
don't let him exchange himself off for
my bishop or any of my Knights but a
good game I think this was the first
time we played or I don't recall playing
before of course it's been a while but
okay yeah good game
you